hi my name is Ludy andrea i work at
Wolfram research and i'll be talking
this year about building maintainable
dynamic interfaces in the notebook front
end
I'm going to illustrate in this talk
many of the lessons that we learned
during those initial interfaces and
especially the lessons that have thought
that I've needed to teach people over
and over and over again as we build new
things in the Wolfram system these are
definitely relevant for people here that
are interested in building their own
dynamic interfaces pardon me that's why
we're here okay so so just by way of
trying to make sure the right people are
here this is not an introductory talk
this is not what is dynamic if you're
looking for those talks I've given them
in the past there are some youtube links
here there's some documentation links
I'm not going to be offended if you
stand up and walk out there are lots of
other nice talks going on right now but
there's lots of good information to get
you up and running with dynamic dynamic
module etc and jason harris is giving a
chat about typesetting i don't really
know what that's going to be but
typesetting is also important for the
talk that I'm that I'm about to give so
at least a smattering of typesetting and
knowledge of the box language would be
useful okay so last year I Illustrated
four principles of dynamic interfaces
can the people in the back row see this
ok ok so the principles of programmatic
generation minimal dynamics maximum
capitulation evaluation blocking these
are very important I encourage you all
to go back and watch that video look at
the notebook but we're going to be
digging into the first one a little bit
more today this principle of
programmatic generation and best
practices for you know how to create
programs that generate interfaces so
that those interfaces can be long-lived
can update over time can you know you
can fix bugs in them even though you've
burned stuff into user notebooks etc and
programmatic generated interfaces take
one of sort of two major categories
there's pre-generated interfaces which
are created once then burn into a file
you know our preferences dialog is like
this are about box
the notebook based interfaces are like
this we're not talking about those today
we're talking about the generated on
demand interfaces things like manipulate
things like the output of alfalfa things
like the predictive interface and things
like interval slider and dynamic
Geographics and we'll be seeing a lot of
a lot of a lot of reuse of this idea
what idea well so let me let me start
off by trying to convince you that
there's something worth talking about
here so most of you know manipulate
built in top level code fine well we
have you know we have all of the dynamic
and layout primitives and control
primitives we have slider and dynamic
and column we can piece them together to
get things that look like manipulate we
can get more clever with localization
and with formatting and labeling and we
get something that looks even closer to
manipulate but the reason that you don't
want to go this route I mean this this
is a great route to go it's important to
build interfaces in in in the Wolfram
language using using functions not just
hand editing the interface but if you
just go down this route to its natural
conclusion you will wind up with an
output that just is a big massive boxes
it's a big so so I should have probably
shown you guys this output so here we
have the dynamic module corresponds to a
dynamic module box the panel panel box
the column goes to a grid box and so on
all these boxes are literally present in
the users notebook we can't change our
minds about the layout of this thing
after we burn these boxes into the users
notebook so if we went down this route
we would have well you see the size of
the scroll of our thumb or do you maybe
you don't write but there are pages and
pages of boxes here that we could you
know if we had gone this route with
manipulate and just dumped these boxes
into user files well that would have
worked it would have worked for the firt
for version 6 when we got around to
version 601 and we wanted to fix that
bug that layout bug where some
manipulates use the wrong
grid option and you know when you had 47
controls and they were arranged just
this way there'd be no way for us to fix
that bug for existing outputs we could
fix it for new outputs but we couldn't
fix it for existing outputs because
existing outputs are just a big mass of
boxes I'm still not to the bottom of
them okay so this would be a bad thing
to burn all these things in we in
addition to the obvious file size bloat
we have you know once we've made the
decision of which boxes to burn in well
then the user is locked into those boxes
the implementation is locked into those
boxes we can't use new constructs in the
front end if if panel box got a new
option we couldn't automatically update
older interfaces to take advantage of it
we'd have to regenerate every manipulate
in the documentation every manipulate in
the demonstrations project so be a huge
undertaking luckily we don't do things
quite this way we satisfy the following
goals we only store what's absolutely
necessary to display the interface and
that interface decisions about display
are made at render time not at the time
that the colonel burns in the boxes into
the notebook the graphic design is
responsive to option changes to platform
changes to environment changes those of
you who went to rob Brigade Scofield's
talked earlier so I manipulate running
on iOS a lot of those things were only
made possible because of the foresight
that we had when we building manipulate
and to enter and to burn into notebooks
symbolic boxes rather than literal boxes
it also lets us do some very nice things
with compatibility but in both
directions so taking older notebooks
opening them in newer versions of
Mathematica taking newer notebooks with
new constructs opening them in older
versions of Mathematica and I'll talk
about details what I mean by that in
just a minute okay so first of all I
showed you the manipulate boxes that we
don't generate now I'm going to show you
the boxes that we do generate so it
still fills just a
a page at this magnification but notice
if you look at that so here we have a
manipulate the layout we see a panel we
see some probably grid layout we see
sliders if you look at the boxes that
are actually generated you won't see a
slider box you don't see a grid box you
don't see a panel box what do you see
well you see a dynamic module box for
storing the state of the interface the
the things that are needed to recreate
the interface state and then you see a
dynamic call to a function that actually
creates the interface a dynamic call to
a function that actually creates the
interface dynamic of course all has only
resolved at render time so those are the
only bits and there's a little bit of
initialization stuff at the end but all
this is is dynamic module of some state
and the dynamic that actually generates
the interface and we've used this idea
over and over and when we introduced
interval slider in version 10 I don't
remember you know this is built on top
of locator pain for the interactivity it
uses our graphics language to draw the
rounded rect slider background and the
highlight background and the thumbs but
if you actually take a look at the boxes
that are generated you don't see locator
pain you don't see graphics box you just
see a very simple call to a dynamic
display function oops right on balance
balance so again it's a dynamic call to
a function that generates the interface
at render time this is this is the
important you're noticing a pattern here
right this this is this is I'm trying to
drive this home we've used this for our
free form input and this is a case where
we've actually changed the display over
time so when we first introduced control
equals some people call it the free form
input feature that goes off to alpha to
find a parse for some natural language
piece of text in version 8 it looked
like this double-decker
where the it would show you both the the
query on top and the parse that it rent
that resolved to on the bottom and we
were we played with this fall during the
eighth cycle and decided you know what
we don't really want this double-decker
thing we want a single decker thing but
the way that this was implemented we
didn't have to go back and regenerate
each of these we just open up this
notebook in version 10 in version 9
version 10 and it looks like this
single-decker how did we do that well I
think by now you probably know it is
because the interface doesn't store
details about the layout it stores the
state that it requires and a dynamic
call to a function that generates the
interface and then this function changed
over time right and there's more again
I'm not going to open the bonus sections
during this talk please look at them and
ask questions about them afterwards if
you want to so any permanent state I
mean we've seen some of this this is a
sum up for some and and a jumping-off
point for the rest the permanent state
is stored in dynamic module and we're
just a dynamic of a function that
generates the interface at render time
this is the key concept there might also
be some custom interpretation around
your dynamic module there might be
tagged boxes interpretation boxes
template boxes I'm not going to talk in
detail about those I'm happy to talk
with you one-on-one about those if
you're interested and then what about
actually details of that utility
function the function that generates the
interface how what are the what are the
lessons that we've learned to make that
utility as flexible and useful and
maintainable as possible and I'm going
to be talking about each of these in
turn so especially low near code passing
by reference communicating with the
outside world and if we have time
detecting when Colonel quits okay feel
free to stop me with questions along the
way and everybody else will groan
because they're all hungry but I'm happy
to answer questions and we can go past
dinner if you like
so storing state we already saw interval
slider doesn't have any state to store
other than the value of the dynamic
variable of the users dynamic variable
there's no other state here there's
nothing it's just a utility function
that generates an interface there's no
additional there's no open or closed
state there's no am I animating or not
state it's just sort of the bare bones
there's no need for additional storage
here unlike manipulate where we do have
a need for additional storage because
manipulate has other features like the
ability to hide and show controls the
ability to kick off an animation what
else can manipulate do has open clothes
of individual controls it has bookmarks
that can be added or removed or edited
and so but if you lend it has the
ability to attach a joystick controller
and move your manipulated around each of
these things requires a little bit of
state stored and so in this case we do
have a dynamic module here to store that
kind of stuff so when you're building
out your interfaces you need to think
carefully about you know what is the
state that needs to be stored what is
the state that we can't sort of generate
automatically the next time around okay
so by way of a simple academic example
here is here is the thing that I've
repeated several times already here's an
example of it an interface function that
creates this construct a dynamic module
of a dynamic of something that displays
an interface and here's the interface
function for this case it's just a
dynamic of a local variable dynamic of a
global variable and some appropriate
controls and then a display of those
control values so let's evaluate this
and see that it doesn't in fact work and
it's not supposed to work but it's
instructive to understand why it doesn't
work and unfortunately I already giving
you the answer to this and the next
subheading title otherwise I would ask
you why this doesn't work we're this
dynamic is calling display of a
and they're at this point a has a value
0 there it looks like Vera already had a
value also about a half and so display
of a ver is getting called as display of
0 comma 0 point 5 these variables are
passing through their values and by that
point you know you can't attach a
dynamic slider to a number you can't
attach a dynamic slider to a number you
can attach to a variable and if you pass
the variables through by reference if
you use holding attributes it will work
the way you expect so this isn't this is
a key technique when building out
interfaces in this way whenever you're
passing dynamic module variables through
from one utility to the other and you
need to be able to change them at one
side you need to make sure that you pass
them through by reference all the way
down so here's an example refactored
that does work and the only difference
is that I've given the display function
a holding attribute yep and here we have
now that this actually does something
something boring but something without
changing the call here oftentimes when
I'm building out these interfaces I
prefer to change this call I prefer to
not have holding attributes on the
utility function and instead use the
holding attributes built into dynamic
and a syntax similar to what slider or
check box or our other control language
primitives use so same kind of thing
here except instead of relying on
holding attributes on the display
function I'm passing these things
through as hell just by virtue of
wrapping them and dynamic so six of one
half a dozen of another I mean pick a
convention and stick with it whatever
you're more comfortable with but but
hold those variables as you're passing
them around okay so that's one aspect of
the technique that's important to
understand another is how to deal with
compatibility issues and making sure
that your older interfaces and your
newer interfaces play well with one
another so you have a single function
and you're really proud of this function
so here's your here's i think it's i use
the same yeah it's the same structure
just panel of a couple of sliders and
dynamic variable and really happy with
this send it to all my users they
evaluate it all over the place and have
lots of notebooks full of this stuff but
then you have an idea well you know what
this list of things i really would you
know i just learned this new function
grid column maybe i can lay these things
out more nicely do i need to tell my
users to go reevaluate all those things
once I update my code base well no I can
just change this so we have this dynamic
utility that's generating the interface
just change its definition and as I
change the definition you see the
existing output was updated so this this
happens to be all in the same session
but this could just as easily have been
you shipping code out to some user and
it updates because that's what dynamic
does yeah notice also that I've added an
argument to this utility function this
argument this is this is my convention
other people might have other
conventions I like to think of it as a
versioning argument of this utility it's
not corresponding to the mathematica
version number it's a version number of
the utility so a version 1 of this
utility did one thing I can support all
of version ones features here so I don't
need to bump the the internal version
number of this utility but if I have
something fundamentally new for instance
that would cause that would cause me to
need new dynamic variables being passed
through I can bump that utility number
and create a new version of the utility
and have newer versions of my package
generate the newer outputs so here we
have you know I didn't I've updated this
utility of this utility which doesn't
affect those outputs but here we have
this new guy that that has a slider 2d
just because it looks different so in
this way we can continue supporting the
older outputs
and in definitely while still developing
and building out new things and
manipulate has use this over the years
what about the other direction what if I
have what if you know I've distributed
my package users have version 1 of the
package they have version 1 of the
interface utility I've created something
new I haven't sent them the new package
yet but I'm starting to send them new
notebooks of mine with these new outputs
well that would be a problem if the
utility that they have had no idea about
this new version the new utility version
which it won't but you can in that first
version of the package you can say if
you don't recognize the calling
signature for this utility you have a
fall through case say you know I don't I
don't recognize this this structure so
here if there's an output that calls a
version of the utility for which I don't
have a definition yet it can just
display some something that says well
you need to you need to contact me to
get the newer version of this is anybody
ever actually seen something like this
in product with manipulator interval
slider or anything like that because it
is in product and we've used this for
manipulate and for a while but I guess
that means that people upgrade regularly
and that's good thing so for instance if
you look if we i'm going to open up the
boxes here and notice that this
manipulate is a version 3 of the boxes i
know if you can see that because
interval slider was added as a control
type to manipulate at some point and so
and so earlier versions so if we had
changed this to I don't know 30 we're
not up to 30 yet but this is what you
would see if you gotta manipulate output
from version 47 of Mathematica of
Wolfram system or whatever we're calling
it in the future and tried to open it in
version 11 this is what you'd see and if
you and likewise if interval slider got
some new option setting and the new
boxes for interval slider couldn't be
rendered in version 11 this is what
you'd see so even though I don't know
what the what next year's boxes are
going to be I can prevent
this year's front end this year's
package from just displaying a big
massive pink boxes or a big massive
internal code sporting all over your
screen which i think is a really nice is
there is there is a much preferable
experience okay so so that's forward and
backward compatibility I think that's
kind of nice we have layout details
changing over time we have the ability
for the boxes to look different on
different platforms on different user
preferences we there's even some code
and maple eight that changes the layout
of your candy fall controls based on the
handedness system option that your
operating system might have and I think
that's only supported on Windows I think
handedness is only is only a thing in
the Windows operating system in Windows
Windows 10 maybe but but the ability is
there and given that it's a dynamic
interface generated at runtime at render
time this all just works and as long as
you use dynamic it's just going to work
what are some other things that aren't
just going to work well one thing that
we don't need to worry about too much
for built-in functions but that you
might need to worry about for your
interface functions is making sure that
your code is loaded before rendering the
interface how might you deal with the
kinds of situations that you encounter
around that well an obvious start is to
just have a dynamic you remember your
your interface is a dynamic function
that runs at render time so that that
interface function can check to see
whether your code is loaded it can do
some you know value Q or down value
arrow down value same q of empty list or
something in this case I just have you
know is does this symbol have a value
and is the value true evaluate this if
it if it hasn't been loaded yet see if
this is true then this displays ready
and if it's not true it's it displays
something that gets you ready yeah so I
click the button and it dynamically
updates to to ready
more often it's useful to rely on
dynamic modules initialization option
especially with synchronous
initialization turned off so that the
initialization can take as long as it
needs to so here's another dynamic that
checks whether the initialization is
complete in the dynamic module and if
the initialization is complete then it
says ready otherwise it says you know
please wait while I'm doing something so
we evaluate this I'll do that once more
watch the cell brackets L bracket lights
up it's evaluating and now it's ready ok
and this is how you know you get really
clever with the please wait indicator
here's a here is a same example but with
a different with a different set of
things saying please wait you know you
can get you can do incremental progress
indication here you could do
indeterminate progress indication as I
have done here this is exactly what
manipulates synchronous initialization
option uses to display that that
indeterminate progress indicator when I
evaluate this there's a very rich and
useful language for dealing with
progress indication and synchronous
versus asynchronous evaluations follow
the link in this bonus section if you
want to know more okay let's see so one
of the techniques that came in very
handy when building out interval slider
was the ability to have an internal
dynamic module variable and a
corresponding external user space
variable and have those two variables
always change one another whenever one
of them was was changed it would
automatically change the other one and
one of those directions is easy if you
have your interface and you're pushing
and you want to push out updates to the
user space you know we have we've built
dynamics second argument to do just and
well it does a lot of things it's nice
and flexible but it can do just that it
can you know evaluate anything including
setting you
external variable so here we have some
external variable that sets a value
between 1.5 and one here we have an
inner value an inner variable whose
value is the reciprocal and whenever i
change this inner slider it's going to
change not only the inner version but
the outer version as well so we get one
of these directions we get the value
pushing out but we don't get the value
pushing back in nothing in the user
space is going to push back into the
local dynamic module box space and you
can't expect the user to push back into
the dynamic module space in fact that
variable doesn't even exist yet so the
user can't possibly know what variable
to push on so the fix for this has to be
in the interface and the fix that I tend
to use in this case is to add a dynamic
wrapper around some key part of the
interface whose purpose is only to track
that external variable and import its
value back in so dynamic wrapper is a
thing whose first argument is displayed
on screen and whose second argument is
tracked dynamically so here we have a
thing that's track dynamically whose
only purpose is to get that outside
variable and import it back into the
value of your inside dynamic module so
here again it pushes the value out but
now if we change that outer slider we
see that it does successfully push its
value back into that interface so this
is this is rather useful technique yes
what what what means i think that is
wrapping versus that that assignment
dynamic the first argument to dynamic
rapper is evaluated when at the instant
the dynamic rapper is evaluated the
second argument is handled exactly as if
it were wrapped in a dynamic it's just
sitting there waiting to be updated like
a dynamic would and those of if there
are people here who or I mean dynamic
rappers is a it's a bit of syntactic
sugar but it's useful sugar and I'd
encourage you to take a look at the
documentation for it okay I had planned
to stop here the rest of my slides or
bonus slides if people want to see more
I'm happy to show more people want to
ask questions I'm happy to try to answer
them well let's find out I'm still not
sure I fully grok the question but let's
quit the colonel and start with this guy
okay so what does work mean so if I yes
I mean once both are evaluated on screen
the connection isn't somehow mysterious
it's going through the value of this
variable and in this case out one is
listening for the value of a particular
variable and out 2 is setting the value
of a particular variable and they have
and they're the same variable and that's
how the dynamic updating system works
okay other questions
if you need to pass additional symbols
through the utility function then then
it'll I'm not sure I understand the
question here yep
you talking about here yep um you could
or you could pass them I mean so okay I
understand the question so the question
is how to support to argument dynamics
in your own interfaces when you pass
them through what do you do with the
second argument and sometimes it depends
on what you're doing in this case I'm
passing them through to another control
and that control knows how to let's do
it this way so the two argument dynamics
inside of slider know how to handle the
second argument already so in this case
there's nothing additional for me to do
but there certainly are cases and I
think interval slider was one of them
where you you do have to build out
support specifically for you know and
not just for the three the list of three
functions case right because there are
other there's one that there's a
function case there's a list of one
function list of two functions list of
three functions some of those can be
none some of them can be automatic it's
not drop dead trivial to do but yes
you'd have to you have to do the heavy
lifting yourself in that case okay well
thanks I'll be here for the rest of the
week and I'll stick around up here if
people have additional questions